You know,
we're learning ways to perturb the brain
and I'm just wondering,
do you think someday that people will be
sort of enhancing,
kind of quote unquote natural creativity
to get people to be more like what we
think of as geniuses or is that just not
possible?
I love the idea of the vision that
there's a way to,
to,
um,
to bring out the genius in all of us and
I wish that there was a way that in our
educational system that we could develop
ways to promote creativity.
We do actually,
we're pretty good at it,
but we could be better that we could
teach people to take risks in education.
We could value more the,
um,
the,
the person that takes the path that is
not the common path.
I think we as a society are pretty good
at that.
We can be a lot better and I think that
that's one of the values of studying or
thinking about genius.
It's a way for us to think about cheap,
let's,
let's get better at this creative
business.
Let's,
let's find that creative spirit in all
of us.
Let's move forward faster.
I think sometimes people think about the
brain has kind of a shortcut to all
these sorts of problems,
you know,
if we just understand the brain,
then we can just go right in there and
just fix things directly.
Whereas it is easy to forget that,
you know,
education itself is altered to the
brain.
Exactly.
I think that we have to think about
brains in the context of our society.
I'm in.
One of the things about genius,
I think it's not just an individual or
just to brain,
it's about opportunity.
It's about somebody who is given the
pathway to actually make a contribution.
It's think of our art musicians,
most of us would consider geniuses.
Bach,
Beethoven,
Mozart.
These are people that,
um,
were put in positions that allow them to
be creative.
The creative spirit comes with many
things other than just the brain.
I think it comes with opportunity.
It comes with resources,
with attitude.
Again,
I like the idea of not thinking of it as
something that the targets and
individual and separates them,
but something that joins us together as
a quality that belongs to all of us.
Well,
because it is true that when people talk
about genius as they are other,
they're there,
they're almost freakish.
Exactly.
And I think that that attitude really
deters people from taking the risk,
but it's a double edge sword.
The genius term is often associated with
a person that really changes the way we
think it could fit with something that
didn't exist before,
that changes the course of our progress
in some fundamental way.
So that person by his or her nature
stands out and is different.
And yet,
and yet all of us are different in our
creative sphere.
And that by incorporating the creative
person into the mainstream,
um,
it might be a way to encourage more
creativity
in a way.
Uh,
you know,
you've been talking a lot about the
things that neuroscientists can't tell
us about genius,
want easy answers and,
and we think,
oh,
these answers are on the brain and,
and you're kind of warning us like,
well,
we,
neuroscientists suite,
we don't know all that much.
The brain is a complicated thing and
it's,
it's a social thing too.
So,
I mean,
what do you think that neuroscientists
can do to help us understand genius
better?
I mean,
what,
what are the kinds of studies that you
think would be like the best ones to do
to make us understand genius as,
as you think of it?
I think that in general,
the study of individual differences,
um,
is a really interesting direction to
take differences in.
Say there's some people that have
extraordinary memory and we can design
experiments to look at the neural
circuitry that's associated with memory
strategies and we learned something
about what makes one person better at
memorizing things than another.
There are differences in um,
how,
how well we do mathematics and how well
we can put things together and
understanding the rules for those
differences is important.
For example,
one of the things that neuroscientists
have taught us recently is that the
parts of the brain are all so richly
interconnected and the extent to which
they are connected has a great deal to
do with function.
So we're talking about say a patch of
cortex over here and another patch over
here and there like cables.
Joining them together.
Indeed,
and how well those connections actually
work,
um,
is thought to contribute a great deal to
our individual differences.
Is it that some people have more
connections than others or bigger
connections or what's what,
what are those underlying differences?
Well,
it's all of the above.
In some cases the connections are
actually more richly innervated.
There are simply more of them in other
cases they to slightly different places.
Um,
in other cases they're just stronger
connections,
which means there's less noise in the
brain.
All of those hypotheses are,
are viable options as evidence for all
of them and they contribute to,
um,
considerable differences between
performances or one person or another.
So if we start to get down to these,
you know,
real kind of biological components of
creativity,
of innovation and of,
you know,
ultimately what we might call genius.
I'm wondering how can we start to kind
of figure out like are geniuses just
born or are they made or what can we
figure can even figure out what the
differences are?
You know,
was,
was Einstein just a blank slate when he
was born and he just happened to have a
really good math teacher in first grade.
I mean,
what,
you know,
how,
how do those connections,
what do we know about how those
connections develop,
uh,
in,
in children and teenagers and adults and
you know,
how the genes play a role in all that.
That really is the $64,000 question and
it is the question that we would like to
answer.
How does the brain do it and how do we
help the brain do it better?
I think that your question really raises
another really important point and that
is how much bigger are questions are
than our science,
our methodology.
We need a genius to figure this one out
because we need to be able to answer
those kinds of questions faster to
answer them better and we need to apply
them to our lives.